وقد بدا بدات رئيسه كوسوفو فيوزا عثماني
استعداد بلادها لاجراء انتخابات محليه
جديده في بلديه شمال كوسوفو التي تقطنها
اغلبيه
وفقا للاطار الدستوري والقانون الحالي
واكدت عثمان خلال لقائها اليوم المبعوتين
الاوروبي والامري على الالتزام الكامل
بالعمل مع من اسمتهم بالشركاء الدوليين
لتنفيذ القانون والنظام في شمال البلاد
والحفاظ على سيادتها واضافت رئيسه كوسوفو
ان السبيل الوحيد لتحقيق استقرار مستمر
وطويل الامد في كوسوفو ومعاقبه من وصفتها
بالجماعات الاجراميه والافراد الذين
استخدموا العنف ضد الشرطه والصحفيين وقوه
حفظ السلام الدوليه
معنى الان من
كوسوفو مراسل الجزيره محمد المدهون نرحب
بك محمد محمد ما الذي تغير في الموقف
خصوصا بعد زياره المبعوثين الاوروبي
والامريكي الى قص
حقيقه ما تغير هو الهدوء في الموقف
الميداني هناك محاوله من الطرفين
لتجنب لون امريكا والاتحاد الاوروبي بشان
ما يحدث رغم ان التركيز والضغط قائم على
الجانب الكوسوفيه على وجه التحديد باعتبار
ان القرار الذي اتخذه رئيس وزراء كوسوفو
والبنكورتي بادخال رؤساء البلديات
المنتخبين اخيرا بقوه الشرطه الى مقر هذه
البلديات كان السبب للاحداث العنيفه
الاخيره ولذلك يجري هذان المبعوثان كل هذه
اللقاءات مع مختلف الاطراف والقوى
السياسيه الحوسبيه لقاء مع رئيس الوزراء
لقاء مع الرئيسه وكذلك لقاء مع قاده احزاب
المعارضه ومع القائمه الصربيه الحزب
الصربي الاكبر في كوسوفو والذي يقود هذه
الاحتجاجات الان هناك اللقاء جارم مع
ممثلي هذا الحزب من قبل المبعوثين
الاوروبي وال وحقيقه هناك ثلاثه مطالب
واضحه طرحها المبعوثان على رئيس الوزراء
البنكورتي المطلب الاول هو خفض التصعيد
المطلب الثاني هو اجراء انتخابات في اقرب
وقت ممكن ان تعاد هذه الانتخابات والمطلب
الثالث هو العوده للحوار الذي يرعاه
الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك شبه اتفاق من قبل
الطرفين الكوسوفي والصربي على الالتزام
بالمطلبين الثاني والثالث ولكن المشكله في
المطلب الاول في خفض التصعيد كيف سيبدا
خفض التصعيد وما دلالات الخطوات التي
سيتخذها الطرفان بشان خفض التصعيد المطلب
الاوروبي والامريكي هو بان تبدا شرطه
كوسوفو بسحب عرباتها وافرادها من محيط هذه
المقار ومن ثم سيغادر المحتجون ولكن حكومه
كوسوفو والرئيسه ايضا في اجتماعها هذا مع
المبعوثين الاوروبي والامريكي اكدوا جميعا
هذه الاطراف الكسوفيه تؤكد ان هناك ضروره
لمحاسبه من يسمونها ومن يصفونها بالعصابات
الاجراميه التي مارست العنف واستخدمت
عبوات حارقه رشقت بالحجاره واستخدمت قنابل
الصوت في مواجهتها مع قوه حفظ السلام
الدوليه الاسبوع الماضي ما ادى الى اصابه
30 شخصا وهناك حقيقه حراك لدى المعارضه
الكوسوفيه يعتقدون ان هذا التعنت والعناد
من قبل رئيس الحكومه لا طائل منه ويؤثر
على العلاقات الاستراتيجيه لكوسوفو تحديدا
مع الحليفين الاوروبي والامريكي كان هناك
توبيخ كان هناك تلويح بالعقوبات وكانت
هناك قرصه اذن امريكيه بالغاء مشاركه
كوسوفو في مناورات للنيتو الاسبوع الماضي
ويبدو ان هناك تلويح بمزيد من مثل هذه
الاجراءات التي لا تسمى بالضروره عقوبات
ولكن هي اجراءات حازمه كما وصفها بيان
جوزيف بوريل الممثل الاعلى للسياسه
الخارجيه والامن في الاتحاد الاوروبي
السبت الماضي الذي حذر من عواقب وخيمه في
حال استمر الموقف الميداني على حاله اذا
كل التركيز الان هو على تفكيك بواعث
التوتر والاضطرابات والمشاكل الامنيه التي
قد تحدث صحيح ان هناك تواري لمظاهر العنف
تبتعد تقل ليس هناك اشتباكات ولكن
المحتجون ما زالوا موجودين في محيط هذه
المقار ما زالوا يطالبون بسحب عربات
الشرطه وقد تتغير الظروف في اي لحظه بما
ينذر حقيقه بمصير سيء ان لم يتم احتواء
هذه المشكله في اقرب وقت ممكن
الجزيره محمد المدهون شكرا جزيلا